he's one of the great shooters in the
nba but uh
i got more important things to ask him
he's our bubble correspondent he is the
uh
star shooter for the miami heat duncan
robinson back on the program
uh duncan given uh the problem that j.r
smith has that he only brought
seven pairs of underwear how many pairs
of underwear did you bring to the bubble
uh i got plenty i got plenty and they uh
they do a good job we get a laundry done
twice a week so
the the rotation is all good okay that
was all i wanted to know duncan
have a good week there uh so
what was it like playing a game in the
bubble after all of this time
it's definitely a little different uh
you know the atmosphere just
being so quiet really some of the
conversations that you can hear
uh throughout a game that you normally
wouldn't be able to hear uh whether it
be on the bench or
uh amongst players but uh it's to be
honest with you i'm pretty used to it
just because
you know as recent as last year i was
playing in the g league and those are
some pretty quiet gyms as well so it's
nothing new for me but
are you going to have to modify what you
say
do you think the guys are going to be
aware of you know the language out there
yeah we quickly learned uh you know
we've played one game but we quickly
quickly learned that the conversations
of miss players gets picked up
very easily on mike's uh one of our
video guys who spends the entire game in
the locker room
basically cutting up film was saying
that he was picking up conversation on
the court
and just told all of us to be weary of
what we were saying so
definitely kind of adds a new dynamic
for sure okay but who would you worry
about
the most on your team saying something
inappropriate
i'd probably jump to jimmy
yeah jimmy butler um you know he
he's a very uh open personality and just
kind of says
what's on his mind so i i would maybe
worry about something being picked up
that uh maybe
maybe the public shouldn't be here yeah
but what about this story where he got
somebody yelled at him for dribbling the
basketball early in the morning
yeah yeah i had heard about that i'm
only a couple doors down from him so
i certainly wasn't the one complaining i
guess it was the the floor below him but
you know when we first got here we had
an initial quarantine of 48 hours so
i guess he got a little restless in his
room okay but do you know who's
underneath you is there another team
underneath you
honestly i don't i i don't i think it's
mostly spread up where uh
you know each team has a floor but i'm
not sure who's on the floor below us no
aside from basketball what do you do in
the bubble
yes there's a lot of downtime uh it's
been great to just be able to catch up
with my teammates
we've had a great opportunity to just
sit down at restaurants get meals that
sort of thing
i brought my golf clubs so i've been
playing at golf a little bit here and
there and then
a couple guys on our staff are really
good fishermen so
i'm not much of a fisherman myself but
i've been able to link on with them and
catch a few
food situation worth complaining about
no i i i think it's pretty good um it's
it's definitely a little unconventional
just in how they have to serve
everything just because they they want
to make sure it's all sanitary and
everything's
compartmentalized but uh it's it's
nothing to complain about there's lots
of options you know the meals that they
give us are solid but there's also
restaurant options as well if
if you don't like what you're doing sir
but are you
are you confident that the season's
starting on time
i am yeah it certainly seems that way uh
one thing that that really jumps out of
you is just the the emphasis on the
safety protocol
and they've done a great job of
enforcing it um you know it's never
gonna be perfect but
they've certainly made it so we all feel
safe here that's for sure
and what about social distancing on the
bench
yeah that that's definitely unique uh
we're all spread out there's like
different rows of the bench and we're
all supposed to be six feet apart
um which is a little funky in theory
just because you know we practice
against each other every day and then
we're out there on the floor and then
for whatever reason as soon as we step
outside the lines then we got to be six
feet apart but
i understand it you know they're just
trying to emphasize being uh
being apart from each other and social
distancing in general
if i gave you 100 threes to shoot
just by yourself yeah how many are you
making
uh so we have like a um an assessment
that we do here
i'm usually somewhere around like high
80s
um the best i've ever had i got uh
93 a little while back so that's that's
my best but i mean that's just
stationary catch and shoot that's still
that's still pretty good that's yeah
that's pretty good
you know if you can catch a rhythm and
kind of get going um
yeah you can just kind of get in that
little bit of his own but obviously it's
a
lot
it's a lot different in the game you
know you got people guarding you trying
to try to stop you from shooting open
one so it's different
but have you ever just let it fly and
then you say to the defender
take that or that's in or face or you
know i
i actually talk a little bit more than
people would would maybe expect
um but it's not so much like trash talk
as much as it is just like
me kind of hyping myself up wait wait
give me a give me a for instant because
given your face there's no way i would
be intimidated if you're talking trash
to me
i don't know if i should take that
personally or what
like i'm nervous about you shooting i'm
just not
worried about you like you know saying
like take that
punk or yeah there's more where that
came from
yeah i'll give you an example when when
jimmy first got to miami
uh his first day there we were playing
pickup and um
him and i kind of got into it going back
and forth we were guarding each other
and
at this point i was i was just basically
trying to make the team
um but it's it's kind of how i play i
have a little bit of a chip on my
shoulder and
uh he went under on a screen and as soon
as i like
let go of the ball basically don't ever
go under a screen
um and let him know that he should have
been there so that's that's kind of what
i
what i kind of do um it's more like
ingest than anything it's not really
like a personal attack on anybody
uh it's more kind of the psychological
warfare i guess
but you wouldn't do that to lebron would
you if lebron went under
on a screen and you let one fly and you
knew it was going in
do you want to probably ah i mean you
know once you get between the lines
anything's possible i don't want to say
i would never um but uh it
maybe wouldn't be my best judgment to do
so
that kind of left the fire within him
well go back to the story you told us
that when you played the first time you
played against him he
he was not even guarding you he
basically was like i'm gonna let that
guy stand out there
he didn't even know how great a shooter
you were yeah i
hopefully by now i've garnered uh
somewhat of a
level of respect or actually honestly
hopefully i haven't and i continue to be
open but um we'll we'll see if if we run
into them in
the playoffs here that'd be a good thing
uh you're uh
you're running your sweepstakes you're
raising funds for the united way
and uh we want to make sure you get a
mention of that uh as well
yeah there's uh almost a little a little
bit less than a week left um in the
sweepstakes it's basically just a
an opportunity for for me to try to give
back to a community in miami that's done
so much for me so
it's a it's a raffle based thing so you
just buy tickets and there's all sorts
of different
prizes the grand prize is basically like
a vip game night
um obviously this is all assuming that
things get back to normal here hopefully
soon
um but there's other ones there's
there's zoom sessions and shooting
lessons and even a round of golf so
that's uh to the let's engage platform
um it can be found on my social media as
well
the links to it all um but yeah i just
thought it would be a
a great way to give back to a community
and especially in these these uncertain
times
i just want to try to use my platform to
to create some positive change
yeah it's let's engage dot com slash
pop-ups to
support the cause there with uh duncan
robinson hey good luck
and uh thanks again for making some time
and uh hopefully we'll get a chance to
talk to you again
all right thank you very much for having
me that's uh duncan robinson
he can sort of talk trash